you're awake early good morning good
morning good morning it's time to rise
and shine
why are you waking up with a camera
don't go back to sleep
how would you define being creative or
creativity see i feel like someone only
creative could explain that to feel like
it's
free thinking having your own thoughts
being like the first person
okay that's fine so would you call
yourself creative
no why not
because i'm the person that goes oh i
should have thought of that
not oh i did think of that
joey do you think you created
who caught his tail
a boy
this has always buggered my mind the
difference between creativity
create and creation the definition of
the word create
according to the oxford dictionary is to
bring something into existence then when
you look at the definition of creativity
it's the use of imagination or original
ideas
to create something inventiveness
so that then means the difference
between creation and creativity
is that creation is a process of
creating
or the end result of a process and
creativity is an inclination
or capacity to create something often
from scratch or something
unusual and unique now to me that all
makes
no sense because it somehow limits the
term creativity the understanding
of creativity itself into something that
only
some people have look we all want to
feel special
but the truth is everyone is equally
creative
the degree of your or anyone else's
creativity
doesn't depend on an innate quality but
rather on how hard you work
you could be as talented as pablo
picasso but if you don't pump out the
work
the creativity is worthless i get called
creative
but let me just show you me trying to
film myself at the age of 14.
hello my name is daniel mace i'm 14
years old
and then six years later when i was 20.
hey what's up my name is my way to the
airport
i'm on my way to the airport now i think
i should say something wrong
i'm trying to think if there's anything
i should say pretty difficult
today
i don't consider myself better or more
creative than anyone else
i just chose the direction of filmmaking
and kept on working
at it and tried to get a little bit
better with each and every video that i
made
today is today is
bring your wife to work day because i
want to prove to the world
and to gabs that she is indeed creative
and so are you by getting gabs to do
something
she's never done before oh my gosh
what am i what do i do you can trust me
[Music]
i've been making films since i was 13
which means
for the last 17 years now
yes that means i'm old dinosaur old
[ __ ] time flies
flies but i'm wise
that was a stupid joke in all
seriousness i've uh
i've been around the block and in doing
so i've created a list
that would help anyone no matter what
line of work you're in or how you define
six fundamental
truths about how to be
more creative okay what are the dreams
follow me one
write about or create what you've
experienced
or know like home like home
don't dive into complex ideals that you
haven't yet experienced
there will be no nuance to the idea
because
newsflash your idea has most definitely
been done before
you can't add your personal touch to it
it will be bland
and unoriginal with influx of creativity
there's no such thing as a new idea but
rather a fresh take on something that
already exists
it's like the respect and humility that
wildlife filmmakers have when capturing
an image of an animal in the wild
they will be any creative enough to be
in the right place
wait for the right moment and capture
the true essence of what was already
there
learn to give up on your good ideas
to make space for your great ideas
doesn't really fit
it is very important to be able to
distinguish the difference
the only way to figure this out is to
have the confidence to believe your idea
is great and
then possibly realize later it wasn't
creativity comes with time
and developing this relationship between
differentiating
what your good is and what your greatest
know your value there's this old story
about father giving his daughter a car
which she looks at as worthless
and after going to a few dealerships and
scrap yards to try find out the values
she proves
this point for straight and she then
calls her dad who convinces her to take
it to the car club
nearby the house for one more evaluation
which she does to find out that the
car's value is actually 20 times the
amount
which any dealership had offered her the
same mayor want to keep the car
the father then tells her to use this
car as a metaphor for life
moving forwards it's for you to choose
where to put your effort
into where you are valued most
essentially everyone is equally as
creative
maybe you are just creating the wrong
[ __ ]
embrace the fears that you suck
[Music]
what try harder and realize that
everybody sucks the first few times they
do anything
let the fear be the fear but don't get
sucked into what i call
purgatory
which is the middle ground between
finishing the film and pressing
export for me the last minute of any
video is so difficult to get done
because i'm scared to let go of the
beautiful journey of what it took to
make the video
and closing that chapter as well as the
lurking idea of what others are going to
think
but the only thing that should matter is
comparing it to your last project your
last dance
your last music piece or film and know
that if it's improving
excuse my french [ __ ] what anyone else
thinks
and lastly don't compare ever unless
it's with yourself you are you and only
you know what feels right so
create that there are some people out
there known as
child creative geniuses and others that
have only been recognized with the
feature film
at the age of 60 it doesn't matter as
long as there's progress
and talking of comparing i want you to
make your own film
okay it's hard be like
that's gonna be difficult i can't do
that
there we go but i'm going to show you
that you can
the trick is is that this film that you
make you have to make with no
footage how am i making a phone without
filming anything
that's a funny question
okay i'm going to give you access to my
storyblocks account
what storyblocks you ask i'll tell you
storyblocks is not only just a sponsor
of this video they also
rad people like i know them and stuff so
i can say that
okay i've made it i have
okay storyblocks is a complete stock
solution for creators
like myself and you now
create a gaps storyblocks offers an
unlimited library
of royalty-free high-quality video audio
and images pretty pretty cool
hang around till the end not just to see
gabby's incredible
piece of art but also there's a giveaway
free [ __ ]
say yay make it big yay
woo you've got five hours on the clock
it's already started ticking
but i'll teach you okay so very very
basically
what's your video about you no
okay make it you want to make it about
dogs the love for dogs okay
instead of spending hours ideating i
gave gabs an idea
does that sound cool i'm not gonna write
the script for you i then gave gabs a
filmmaking with stock footage
lesson which included write a voiceover
open a premiere project record the video
get stock footage in the easiest way
possible find a song and then
edit it all together i then left the
room with
low expectations because this is her
first time ever doing this
let me know if you need anything you
promise
baby
i'm finished you finished oh my gosh
okay
i'm so proud of you we're gonna export
it
and we're gonna go watch it at home okay
done
you ready ready
nervous no what
you press play
you may be a dog but to me and more
you're the light in my fog you put up
with our wall
it's just a dog other words from someone
who's never seen vlog
and his walls have not begun through
thick and thin
you've stayed by my side even when i
can't win
even when hope has died you're the angel
i wished for
you're the best friend i've had you're
all i wanted and more
and i love you like mad i can't thank
you enough for the things that you do
when times are tough i'm so glad i have
you
[Music]
you made that
what that's insane
that is madness i quit my job
baby like how did you find that process
pretty simple
simple i didn't know making a video
could be this easy
okay calm down david fincher don't
forget you did have
the help of storyblocks which really
does make the process
i guess easier and it's a no-brainer to
have story blocks as part of your
toolkit
and on that note i'm giving away two
separate year-long
unlimited all-access plans to story
blocks
all you have to do is subscribe to their
youtube channel which i'll link below
and then
i mean obviously you have to subscribe
to mine hey i mean that's
uh yeah and then comment below the way
that you describe creativity and and
then i'll select the base two
and get into contact with you and give
you this epic prize
and then yeah other than that don't
forget
you're awesome brew and we will see you
next week
[Music]
you